what will happen it's these days
i think we should start maybe okay
maggie do you want to do the interest
okay
are we letting people in
what what do you mean uh i mean that
happens oh yeah yeah it's it's public
and i was watching the company
i think it's stabilized now so we should
be good to go
okay um hello everyone so it's
today is the last day of the bootcamp
week and we want to use the last day
to go over the very fundamentals
of optimization stochastic programming
and simulation
so we have professor alex shapiro
i think many of you know his name from
his papers
so like for example i learned a lot
about stochastic organization
from alex papers so alex has made so
many foundational contributions
in stochastic programming so he will
give us a tutorial
on the basic of stochastic programming
and how
it could be useful in reinforcement
learning
i should start yes first of all
thank you very much for inviting me and
i
i was listening to some of the talks
during this week
and i suppose i will talk today from
some
different point of view on
somewhat i will say related problems
what i will try to do today
i have saved more less than two hours i
will try to give a certain point of view
on stochastic programming stochastic
programming has its all
origins going back to beginning
basically of linear programming more
than 60 years ago
and developed a long very different
lines
of different ideas from what
they say mdp control and that
so during a talk i will
also post various questions
which i think are relevant or important
to what i say i do not pretend that i
know
everything it will be of course
too much but a again i would like to
present certain point of view
this point of view of course is my point
of view this very large extent
so many people may not agree with what i
say
or it's just no as usual mathematical
results are usually precise
but the conclusions and what we say
mean out of that could be quite
different so at least i hope
that it will start discussion
of different ideas this is my fault
okay so let me start
now i i
this is what is here i suppose you can
see that right
this is very very general formulation of
multi-stage stochastic program and there
are many questions about
that this is very flexible way of this
of the modeling certain type of
problems and i'll try to explain what it
means
this formulation is very general
probably too general to be of any use
right now but some conceptual things
probably already
i can explain here now uh
let me from the beginning say several
things
okay what is the difference
here from the class of the problems
that they addressed by stochastic
problems somewhat related
to mdp and control but
the modeling and the solution approach
is quite
different so what is written
here is not a control problem
now this can be just different can be
once a semantic
but it's deeper than that this is
optimization problem
and the implications of that so this for
example
uh objective function i will talk about
that more in details about that
it's not reward or regret
now this is
data process it's not in this type of
applications
it's usually not noise it's a certain
pro uncertain probe process it's a data
that one observe
now it's a i will talk about more
details now about this formulation
and that but
for notation and just approach is that
the basic idea of all this type of
optimization
problem is one make decisions
based on information and every time
period
creates a finite horizon at every time
period based
on the information one has
how this so basically one
what information usually we supposedly
know
the past but we don't know the future
so how to model that is a big question
right in this particular case for now
right i will assume it is random the
process
data process you can think about it the
sixth sequence of observed
number of parameters modeled as random
it's a big
big thing and i will comment on that
later why it's random what does it
mean now of course when you
have stochastic causes there's a huge
theory going
on centuries about that so
often the information in modern way
is modeled by filtration by a sequence
of sigma fields
it's convenient from a mathematical
point of view in many ways and may
sometimes i may do that
but it's very non-intuitive so at the
moment
you may think about that as a random
process that is going
on this is what you observe this is a
data
it's not noise and this is just notation
this is a history of my process
okay now another very important point
here that i will
make throughout this that in the
beginning
before we observe any realization of the
data
right it's deterministic
at the first stage when a make decision
is deterministic
it's before we observe any realization
of the data
now again this is too genuine this
what we really uh mostly i will talk
about
linear phase in other words the
objective functions
here suppose we minimize are linear
this is my how my decisions these are
supposedly cost
and these are type of constraints
usually this type of balance equations
that one has
and you can see this is a certain
structure it has a certain structure
so at the moment time t we only look at
the previous period
this is important this type of markovian
structure here
so now what we try to
what i will list i release there many
questions immediately questions which
come with this formulation and we'll
have to think about that
for some of these questions we have some
type of
maybe reasonable answer some of them i
don't know
so the first question what does it mean
that we want to solve this problem
think about it so basically
we look at the process here
you may think about that is just these
parameters they may depend on some this
is data
that observes some of them can be around
them and so
so at the moment we write
we write the expected value the moment i
write the expected value i assume
certain probability distribution of my
process
at least from theoretical point of view
and let's say
so how do i model it how do they will
talk about that
but even now what does it mean that i
solve this type of problem or even this
one
general okay so i supposedly i give
to the user algorithm rule
how to make the decision depending on
what data that we observed
after every time period c
and i wrote it like that okay
so i assume from now
that the probability distribution of my
process it's random process
does not depend on my actions this is
another thing
it's possible to do it more generally
but as we'll see
here the convexity of that will be
extremely important
if we look this linear right it's going
to the origins of linear problem and
it's convex problem
the moment i'll start to assume the
dependence of this distribution on my
actions it destroyed on the exit as
we'll see
so model at the moment again it's very
important
i will have this process we modulate the
random process with some
issue to save some probability
distribution
and then our decision is a function of
that
so
this is completely at this moment it's
quite vague
what i mean by solving that why why
because generally nature has infinite
number of possibilities
so from modeling point of view when i
model the data say using time series
something like that
typically it has continuous distribution
noise usually assumed to have a normal
distribution and things like that
so if my data if my decision are
function of that it's infinitely
dimensional problem
because they they run
how to solve that it's a very very big
questions
in reality in practice people people
usually look at the first stage solution
which is deterministic this is what
decision you make
now at the moment before we observe any
realization of the data
right and then as we progress as more
information is coming
usually it's recalculated so
as we see this uh the whole concept
what does it mean to solve that is not
something that obvious and we'll
i will talk about that so from
mathematical point of view
if i formulate it like that now i need
to give to the user
sometime type algorithm or procedure how
to calculate optimum decisions depending
on what we observed up to time t
on the past on the information he or she
has
okay so i will talk about that more what
does it mean
now the next obvious question is
can it be solved numerically because
from the beginning
the stochastic problem went into the
numeric
can we solve something you can read this
and uh i'll comment on it later
so what it's is it really can resolve
that at the moment
it's too big it's infinite dimensional
i cannot put it in the computer in that
way i have to make some type of
discretization
next question i will try to convince you
that there's a huge difference here how
many stages we take
actually in the beginning at originally
it was two stage
and even for two stage there are many
many questions
i will talk about that in a moment so
when you you plan something and it's
written here we look at the head
for if say final horizon i'll talk now
for the prime authorized
and say 100 stages ahead
is it reasonable what does it mean
because
at the end i will probably use only
first stage solution
and i'll recalculate trying to look in
the future is using certain type of
destruction of them
is it reasonable it's not clear
now so you know another so one of the
question
what is this what is the value of
solving
multi-stage problem for many stages in
fact
in some simple cases it's possible to
show that optimum policy is my own
one need to go look only one stage
effect
it's very exceptional so it's not clear
now next a i listed all types of
questions that should somehow
be addressed
when i write with expectation from
mathematical point of view
it's assumed certain type of probability
distribution
how we know this probability
distribution what i really observe
is a data and everything else is modern
okay some people now say that there is
no
model there's only data i don't think
it's so
right so any model cannot be precise
in some cases it can be even very
questionable what it means
so how we know the probability
distribution of that
now next question in this formulation
we write expected value why
what a really justification of expected
value expected value means
that we optimize it on average the
particular realization of that can be
very different from average and in fact
we average air in two ways
the expected value itself is averaging
over the distribution
but we also in some sense average over
the
period of the time
if one look at say time series model and
this is how people do that because
typically
when you have realization of the data
your data
you have just one realization i cannot
go back in time and repeat my
observations so how we model them how we
know the distribution what does it mean
why we optimize on average
now there's also question of time
consistency
there's a lot of misconceptions about
that i'll talk about
later and last question i don't know
well have time to talk about that
why we minimum optimize the total cost
look we look fine in the future and we
minimize the total cost is it reasonable
it's not obvious okay
now uh let me talk again i don't have
answers to all questions
but i will try to give certain point of
view and some may agree with me some
hey originally this uh
this whole approach was to that was
by constructing scenarios
what is this scenario right scenario is
some type of
one can look at different ways one
possible way if looked at that is
discretization
of my random process once
this can happen with this in the future
that can happen in the future
usually you can see in the books they
represent it is scenario three
this can be what can really happen in
future and then
one assigned to that some numbers which
people call probabilities right what it
really means is not that clear
okay so
uh if i
try if we try to do that try
to we need to discretize this probably
continuous
process by
discretizing this otherwise i cannot put
it in a computer i need to do
calculations
by doing that what does it mean what i
probably might really solve how good
approximation
and so on so i will try to separate two
things
yeah right and actually probably even
three
okay when we look at that let's look at
a
linear as we'll see there's a huge
problem with even with link
there's from modeling point of view
usually the distribution of that my
random process
has is modeled as a continuous
distribution
heaven continuous distribution adam
every model is wrong
everybody knows that so this is the
first type of problem
okay so but another is
let's refer to that true model true
problem that
we model now then we discretize that in
order to solve that numerically
to put it in a computer and that
introduce additional error
in our in our view of the word
even after that we cannot solve as we'll
see
we cannot solve the problems with high
accuracy it's out of question as well
so it will con additional error can we
control these errors
can we say something about that i will
not talk about modeling error
this is a very very big question but i
will not talk about that
but at least next can we somehow control
or estimate the error of our
discretization
and the error of numerical solution
okay now let us start
let us talk with this just
two stage okay from a control point
you write you have this many many stages
but originally it started with just two
stages
and as we'll see even in that case there
are many
non-trivial problems
i will talk about lean so here
right when you look at that it's all
linear here
and what is random here the first stage
the decision
is deterministic and then we have
second stage decision which is adjusted
to realization of my random date when i
at the first when i
in the beginning when i make decision on
the first stage i don't know what
realization of that
after i observe realization of my random
parameters i
make some other optimal decision which
is written here
say linear right so
how can can i solve that now i
just think about that for the moment to
solve that
i suppose this first is deterministic
that but this is a function
of my random data even this container
has continuous distribution
all these parameters some of them it's
infinite dimensional problem
so i need somehow to do discretization
of that
so this neutralization we are called
scenarios
which is natural this is what may happen
in the future
to which assigns certain type of
probability so if i'll have five
number of possibilities okay
with respect to probabilities i can
write it as
one large linear problem
the complexity of this problem numerical
complexity of the smallest proportional
to the number of scenarios this number
of possible discretization
that i added yes yeah we got a question
so could you
explain like what a scenario mean in
particular
what does scenario mean here scenario
means realization
think about that is just okay
in a multi-stage case it's a sample path
this is your particular what can happen
think about that as
just one random vector it has components
say
100 parameters right you say
okay this may happen this may happen
this way
you may describe one make discrimination
of random
distribution i'll come immediately to
them
so you will think about that as you look
at the
distribution discrete distributions with
the score
this parameters yeah so
is the sample path so far that is the
scenario right
you can think about that here really to
call it sample path
is because it's just one vector in
general yes
uh this is this scenario is what may
happen
and you assign to that certain
probability this is called distribution
yeah about this discretization of your
probability distribution
uh thank you another question from the
audience is
so the random process cause i t
so is that controlled or run or
uncontrolled
we assume here with this is data
it's not it's it's not controlled
probably we have no control at all
this is what we observe
so it's just a stochastic process and
this distribution won't be affected by
our actions
uh first it's not noise
it's model for our data which we observe
i'll give a half of time i'll give
examples after that
this is the framers this uh
power generation this is how much water
this a every month is coming
to the the object
so it's not noise
and with you here at the moment we
assume that probability distribution
where we try to model it
does not depend on our actions
so it's outside we have absolutely no
control of that we it's the best we can
model that
and again it's not noise which is or
disturbances that usually is human
control conceptually it's very different
it's a
yeah thank you so uh one last question
from the audience
yes so so this formulation is certainly
related to markov decision process right
so can we model all markov decision
process in this way
and how i would say how rich or like
that is one
special case of another and how do we
compare the two formulations
a a this is very good question how we
model the process
itself and i hope i'll have time to talk
about it this is
very very important question now
and
from as a statistician i know only one
way
which approach to things like that
the modelling is always markovian
but a from this point of view to assume
that my process
iid is not natural at all
usually there is a sum of
autocorrelation dependence and this is
very big problem
okay so how to model that is say
again you have to think about that
different way from this
control and mdp that iso so far
it's data it's not noise
which we try to model how to do that
it will be probably it's i have to give
a whole class on that
please if it's still not clear ask me
because this is what i'll say after that
we'll probably make no sense if we will
not
decide about that yeah so so just to
help
everyone to get on the same page if i
might chime in
uh so this uh psych
process uh it is the auxiliary process
that
is going to impact what decisions you
should be making but you're not
controlling but it's
it's like you are a mark there is a
market that you're not controlling
and then you're controlling your
portfolio that would be one example
right
um no i think it's a
a it's probably not very good example
demand for some product
demand okay if they see your action
this price or may affect the
distribution of demand but we assume
here that it does not
this is probably not very good example
but say
when we pray well produce electricity by
using water
how much water you have every month it's
uncertain because it depends on rain
rain and it's absolutely outside of our
control we have historical data this
example said i'll try to show
and we try to model that and try to
focus
what will happen in the future and every
forecast has error in distribution
right right so there is a time
potentially and
very often more often than not a time
correlated
process that is impacting how you should
be making decisions
this is what is captured essentially by
this formalism
where uh xt's uh these are reactions
and the usual terminology that people
use in reinforcement learning or mdps
this is a different point of view on
that
again our decision is history of the
process
which we observed yeah yeah it's like if
you have a finite horizon mdp you would
take the whole history especially if you
have
partially of partial observations or
what not right
slightly different when you look at this
essay
mdp you have your action
this uh this realization action
realization history
here our decision uh functions of the
history of random process
uh it's not completely true as we'll see
later when we
try to solve but at the moment this is
information that i have at the
every time period this absorbs the past
i know that this is all information
and i have to make decisions right
so so you're observing these things go
ahead man
now and also this constraint set for x
for action xt
so why does the constraint depend on
only the last random variable rather
than the entire sample path
that we can solve
this markov and type of structure
because
theoretically and in some books i can
put it depending on all the history of
them
but then it will be computationally
in intro and in many cases it's
reasonable
it's kind of funny that the constraints
that is the one that is mainly
impacted by the exogenous impulse this
messiah it is history that
that comes in uh it's uh
yeah and and through that
um that's how it is kind of appeared
right
uh this is how we
okay if you look for example control
formulation
say this inventory model this similarity
what is important here is this this
you can think about that as this linear
control
in the sense yeah you have linear
dynamics linear
cost and linearity is extremely
important
and the setup sorry
the set of admissible actions is
restricted in every time step to this
convex set
that depends on where you have been
right so it's like
you would need to build a state and then
the state is going to determine
um uh the set of removable actions that
you can take and then you
make a linear update to the state so you
could reform it
lingard control problem this linear
constraint
uh growing state dimension though
because ift
you know um
is is the state dimension growing they
said separation between state and
controls
here or connection unstable
here it's it's just optimization problem
it's not control
typically these are balance equations
that connect what
decision now and what we have before
okay um okay
i'll have to go to a really interesting
part so
i hope i'll be able at the end with
these examples
it's a good discussion okay
thanks so uh
so numerically if we look at even two
two-stage problem
right it's in control it's probably not
even relevant
but here it's very relevant that you
have with this
this is origins actually of the decision
that i want to make now
then something happens i observe
something it's linear everything here
and i make my optimal decision right and
usually except later one of the big
question is with the question of
feasibility of my decision at the second
stage
so if it doesn't i don't do not produce
enough electricity
i suppose i can buy it somewhere else at
big
price this was actually origins of this
ideas
okay now the question is can we really
solve
numerically so i hope now it's
what scenario means is just
discrimination of what can happen
now uh i don't know it looks that i will
be not able to talk too much about net
but
one of the questions that i ask why we
optimize this on average
this is also question to you to control
where when you
have stochastic this there probably it's
more relevant but here it's a big
question
right expected value by from beginning
optimizer to nurse
it doesn't take into account the risk
what i mean the risk is that it could
happen that
but for particular realization my cost
remember i minimize their cost it's not
regret or
can be much larger than the average
and it's not good people don't like it
can i control the risk this
risk also this a theory is has
very long history recently it's a
it's a certain type of approach to
people to risk use
i don't know if i'll have much time to
talk about that
but it's it turns out that concept of
the risk even in two stage
we replace this expectation of director
of that by some type of the
risk functional or some functional of
that it's closely related to what people
now say distributionally robust
what distribution is robust if i go back
to my questions
right how do i know the distribution
i know it's never known so the best it
can be estimate remember it's data
i estimated from the data so how this i
can
deal with that so one of the possible
approach one take the worst possible
case
one specify the whole set of probability
distribution instead of one
right and take the worst possible case
it turns out that there is a close
relation between risk
and this what is now called distribution
in the robust optimization
the same the same can be said about the
control
right and mdp and then our papers start
to appear with a lot of mistakes
okay i i don't know how much i'll be
able to talk about that but
at the moment you can think about that
one replace that by
some type of functional which is not
linear expectation is linear
and it's now weight i will see later
now uh if we look in two stage problem
okay the two possible formulation which
are in sense equivalent
you can think about that as dynamical
equation
right here we'll look at as one we write
it with
one very large linear problem depending
on how many scenarios
here we summarize it here this in this
function
right this function which is this value
you can think about this very simple
dynamically
with our programming equation just to
stage
so uh what can happen
and this is already important here and
in fact it's crucial sometimes
i make decisions here first stage
decision this is what i made before
observing
any data and then some realization
can happen it could happen that this
linear program will be infeasible
no solution what to do in that case
right uh one decide about how much
but how to satisfy the demand but at the
second stage
this to make some decisions actually it
cannot be satisfied
blackout in a big city is quite bad how
to deal with that there are many
solutions yes so
that means that the value of this this
is the value of the second stage
dependent
on my decision at the first stage and
random vector here's just one random
vector
a promotion point of view people put it
plus infinity it's
give it an infinite penalty for that
takes this it's make it say this in
other words
one tried to exclude that how to deal
with
it it's not clear at all because what
can happen
is that i make discretization
here and i generate certain scenarios
but it
doesn't represent everything possible
with infected in second stage
so then i make the decision based on
that i solve this linear problem
if it is not too large i can put it in
some solvent and solve that and
give me this something else happened not
from scenarios which i constructed
and it's invisible i cannot even
implement it
so it's a big question what to do with
that
all right so another big question i
don't know probably i will not have
time to talk about the so-called time
consistency
should i let me very quickly say that
even to stage it makes sense to ask this
question
because i if i solve this problem this
suppose i solve this problem suppose
everything is okay
okay i make decision here
and then i decision yeah and this is
if i look at that from the point of view
of first stage
i make assumption about distributions
when probably
then i see the realization of the data
should i compute my decisions you see
this
if i solve this problem that give me
first aid decision and the second stage
decision which is
adjusted to any particular realization
of the data
i solved that and then i absorb the data
i have joffrey
saying should i compute it's not obvious
question
this is called time consistency and it
turns out to be
right in some cases not trivial question
even in two stages
all right so if i did it incorrectly
maybe at the second stage my decision is
for some particularization of that is
not random
it is not optimal is it good
i don't know it's a big question
i i don't have much time let me go on
because otherwise i will not say
anything interesting
now one question
is now which should be addressed from
the beginning and this is a relatively
recent
way of looking what is the complexity of
so
even to stage problem
do you see that because what i promise
to solve here i promise to find
optimal first stage solution which is
deterministic
and for second stage i will give to the
user
the decision that they would make
depending on theirization of the data
now by doing that i have to make
discretization of
my random vector here it's just because
of the stage just one random vector
this is actually answer to some of the
question it was asked
from the beginning right think about
that
is d dimensional random vector it has
joint distribution
suppose i have idea about this
distribution
and then i make discretization of this
distribution
i and they call it scenarios
to which i assign corresponding
probabilities
the from statistical point of view the
simplest possible case
is when components of this this is
parameters
random parameters where they have
statistics stochastically independent of
each other
think about some type of distribution
normal distribution
okay i have to discretize that
just one dimensional distributor suppose
i use for one
for each part component 10 points
not that much right i try to approximate
continuous distribution
by discrete distribution with 10 points
the total
number of scenarios grow exponentially
because it will be it's a power of that
and it was a show you can see this
this is the first paper of that
uh that from deterministic point of view
by deterministic i saw this what is
called deterministic analog content
this is scenarios are solved and they
use typically first only first stage
solution
computationally intractable it's
understandable why
because the when i enter this
think about m just 10 points not that
much
even three but d can be quite large
number of parameters random parameters i
use
very quickly it becomes astronomical
number
but the number of the points this data
that
i enter in the computer grow linearly
with dimension
d when the number of these scenarios
grow exponentially
it was shown uh
this is very good paper is a relatively
recent paper from the deterministic
point of view
the even two-stage even linear
even with this simplification cannot be
intractable in other words it cannot be
solved with
high accuracy in principle
and indeed it doesn't mean it doesn't
make sense to try to solve this type of
problem with accuracy 10 to the minus 5
and y 6 because error is coming
from modeling usually for bigger than
that so
what one can do so you can see this
first everything is that nobody paid
attention to that
but then it can really be
something being solved
okay so the b and it's it's again it's
my opinion
this it's still this scenario approach
is very
hell saying looks very intuitive you say
okay you go to practitioner and say okay
this
was what scenarios what can happen in
the future
we signed to that some chances by this
experts and this is what we try to solve
okay now the big
progress on that was development of
randomization
and right now it's become somewhat star
almost standard but in the beginning it
was a big resistance to that
i'll explain why now
if i suppose i have fixed point x this
is my objective
value again you can think about it as a
value
of second stage problem it depends on
random data
randomly when i write expected value
no it's integral can it be computed
just the expected value for multi when
you have many many parameters the answer
is
it cannot be it cannot be computed with
high accuracy
usually no there's some cases where it
can be true in general
it can so there's no hope here
to solve that in a because i cannot even
compute the value at
some given point with high accuracy
there's no way i can
solve this problem in high accuracy and
this was a proof
so one of way to do that
is to use a monte carlo something
and again it's going a long way back
so uh what is obvious way to do that
is that one a random sample of that
where n is the sample size should be not
too large as we'll see otherwise will be
notable so
and one replace this expected value by
what is called this there's different
names of that this is called
today it's called sample average and one
solve this problem
so one replace is a one solve this
problem by replacing this one by that
now again there are a lot a lot of
misconceptions about me it has
this type of approach was used in
statistics for
some countries maximum likelihood in
some senses like that and
this is basically origin of say monte
carlo simulation
uh what is what is probably new recently
is that was shown that in some cases
can be quite efficient in some sense
and i will talk about that now what is
obvious justification of that
is low flash numbers okay
by low of large numbers this average
will converge to that same probability
of one
but it's not good enough because uh
what is the error this it's well known
that
monte carlo type of methods are not very
accurate and
suddenly classical central limit theorem
if i
fix some point under certain conditions
it's a converge to normal and the error
of order
is a stochastic order one over square
root of
n and nothing one can do there's a
quasi-monte carlo method it's
questionable if they are useful or not
but in principle one cannot solve that
and it's possible to show that
interestingly enough
the optimal value of this problem has
more or less the same rate of
convergence
as for fixed point not exactly
there's a it's quite well understood now
what
happens here but it's a this first type
of result
so the rate of convergence of this of
this monte carlo
is basically of order one over square
root of
n what it means is that if i want to
reduce my error by
one digit 10 times i have to increase my
sample
size about hundred but very bad
okay not much one can do about that
they all type of virus reduction
techniques sometimes it helps sometimes
no
that's a big question this is
asymptotics
it's also another question is
if i want to guarantee that i solve
this probe my original problem
this is my original problem probably
with continuous distributions
of here yeah
by sampling how large i need the sample
size
in order to solve this with certain
accuracy
replacing them excellent this is natural
question
all right and this is a this is a
one can give certain type of guarantees
of that they are not practically useful
and not using calculations but they give
us some ideas
what a really complexity of the what is
called sample complexity and this is go
through all this
uh because a in a stochastic program it
starts to be unknown in the sample
language approximation
another it's called and it has different
names the idea itself is almost obvious
it was
used in different areas by many people
over the many years
okay so what is there and it's not
surprising
so the sample size is a draw more or
less
as a square is 1
over epsilon square epsilon is the
accuracy that i want of the first stage
okay i
know this question if this theory is now
one can improve that and then many
better start to appear on that now
one of the question is less if you want
one
how to extend to distributionally robust
and risk ever second some results are
available but it's far from being
complete
okay now
now please when should i stop
yeah there is a quick question uh
yesterday
right there for the distribution are
there any extensions to
heavy tail what not like people looked
at that you know
robustness in that sense yes there may
there's this number of results okay
here we talked about expected value now
a if you look at distribution in a
robust or
risk reverse what is called with risk
they are very much related to each other
there is number of results of that and
they are not real
there's a certain result of it but it's
not complete and it's very much depends
it's not real question there's some
results up there
but it's not complete it's surprisingly
even at this type of this this this this
is a
became well-known now for risk averse
there is no complete analysis
surprisingly technically become
very became very very difficult
okay again if somebody is interested in
what i'm saying i will be glad to talk
more but i
i restricted there by the time
sure i think we can go on still
just use the time i can continue or we
stop now
yeah i think so maybe what do you think
sorry
i think we have we could have five more
minutes
okay you'll tell me when to stop okay
now uh so i i tried to show you that
even two stage as
many questions which are not completely
obvious
or clear right and two-stage also has
many many applications like hundred
thousand papers
they use all types of things now
uh from what i said so
far by using this randomization method i
thought
by the way this sa method is not
algorithm
it's just approach to that there's a
very efficient
algorithms using sub gradient or
stochastic question i don't have time to
talk about net
now what i want to say from this point
of view
of the sample complexity how large
sample i
need to solve the problem with
reasonable accuracy
computational complexity from scenario
point of view is
always proportional to that because
these are scenarios i generally
every my every here every point i
generate here
you can think about that's a new
scenario randomly
we should do this assign probability one
over n
and then one still has to solve the
problem so if n
is a billion we didn't get anything
all right so it should be not too large
otherwise i will be not able to solve
and then small is proportional to that
so but this from this point of view the
number of scenarios that one try to
construct in some irrelevant
what is important is if you can see it's
certain type of
there are completely different type of
things for example what are variability
of that
why because anyway we generated random
so from this point of view
number of scenarios that the people use
finally is irrelevant
now originally
this when this was moved from two-stage
to multi-stage it's
also was considered in terms of
scenarios
usually constructed by what is called
scenario three
this is what can happen this is very
first and beginning we have this
length and fat and conditional back and
so on
so from scenarios point of view of
linear it's also
possible to formulate is linear test as
one
large linear problem which is
called deterministic equivalent
complexity of that is proportional to
number of scenarios
num scenario is a sample path you have
the data
this is what may happen how you modulate
the big question
so but here from some there's a huge it
turns out there's a huge
difference from sample complexity of
two-stage and multi-stage
so uh i would even say
that we have quite good idea today
how to solve quite reasonably solve
large class of two-stage problems even
with the
integer variables we have very little
very little it's this there's some
success but the big big question how to
solve
multi-station and this is very much more
related to what i
heard here with control in mdp
okay and this is what i will try to talk
a maybe now with before after the break
theoretical analysis show immediate
now if i have stages i have to model the
whole process
this is random process that is going on
here
right
and the way how i have to model that
is condition because this is the whole
process conditional
i make my decision conditionally what i
absorb so
far so
the number of the sample if i want to
model it
i think the simplest possible with some
type of markovian structure
of them
and the number of scenarios the sample
path grow
also exponentially with the number of
stages
so if somehow by using randomization
i was it was impossible to deal with the
two stage this
static type of problem exponential draw
number smell because
draw of the number of parameters
here we have another exponential growth
number of stages
and that kills it so there's a
know there's a general result you can
see
it looks nice right now there's some
parameters there i want to write it more
precisely
but basically if i need to approximate
the whole process
in reasonable way i have to discretize
every at this at every stage
conditionally
so i make 100 discretization first time
and 100 conditional attribute
designation
then i it should i should multiply that
because number of scenarios number of
sampled paths
it's conditional draw exponential
because of that
the computational complexity of that
in terms of scenarios sample path is
like that
so if t equals 10
right it's useless i cannot do that
because number of scenarios
start to become astronomical very
quickly
so what to do with that and
we don't have a simple answer to that
there's some successes but it's
i probably will
but it seems to be in principle this
type of problem
are computationally intractable the
weight however even linear the weight
card was formed
sample complexity grow exponentially
so but i will talk at least some type of
successes
okay so now several questions before
this uh this theory
right give you upper bound on the number
of these
scenarios that one on number of
discretization
they're more precise this way i i wrote
it's very
generic and more precise now uh
it's upper bound this is sample size
method
what about low bar is it best what can
do
but there is some type of results were
but not many
right in other words is it tight can
anyone do
from this point any better than that it
looks to be correct
but it's not it's not fine central in
ethereum type of result that i show for
two stages it's not even clear how to
formulate
hey alex probably we could like stop
right here and pick it up like in 30
minutes
so it's not even clear what it means
because
here you have one sound here we have
this you
sample here
every time it's not one sample how you
want to formulate that
i will talk about that later but it's
not there's no
no type of results the this really the
last uh this is a
large duration type of results similar
to that for that we have
quite good idea they also call
concentration inequalities
that it's not even clear how to
formulate them
how do they distribution robust
risk of those it's there's some results
there's so many questions
more should be it's uh
yeah we should probably stop right here
and answer
these questions in 30 minutes so what
questions
okay i mean you have a list of questions
on your slides are you going to talk
about it
how
i don't see any questions no i'm talking
about the questions
you raised on your slides so let's
get back to those questions after the
break
okay okay good thank you